Madagascar is a big island off the east
coast of Africa, and is one of the
poorest countries in the world.
On average, people there earn just over a
dollar a day. And right now, there's a
drought in the south - the worst in 40
years.
Just look at this satellite image, it
uses infrared technology to show whether
vegetation is healthy. Basically, the
darker the brown, the worse it is. And
there's a lot of dark brown. Almost
everyone there relies on growing their
own food, so this drought is devastating.
More than a
million people in southern Madagascar
are what the U.N. calls, food insecure. That
means they can't get enough nutritious
food to eat. And out of those, around 14,000
are in what's called ‘phase 5’ - the
catastrophe stage. That's when people
start dying of starvation or
malnutrition and disease. And that number
is expected to double by October, because
no one's sure the rain is going to come
and Madagascar is heading into what's
known as lean season.
So how did Madagascar
end up here? Well, there are lots of
reasons. For decades, the governments have
been pretty unstable, and the country
ranks near the bottom in a lot of
important categories. Whether it's income,
corruption, or what the World Bank calls
‘human capital’. Basically, whether a
country invests in things like education
and health. That's the baseline.
Then you add COVID-19, the complications
that brings,
and then there's climate change.
So we know that greenhouse gas emissions
are leading to more extreme weather. That
was one of the big conclusions in a
recent report by the IPCC - the world's
top climate scientists. And when it comes
to Madagascar, there are really two
things going on. One on land, one at sea.
Let's start on land. Southern Madagascar
is already pretty dry, but the last six
years have been exceptionally warm. When
the air is warmer, the molecules move
further apart and the air can hold more
water vapor, which means it can suck up
more moisture from the land.
So if the land is already dry because of
a lack of rain,
warmer air makes it all worse. It's like
the atmosphere is thirstier.
Now, what's happening in the sea is that
global warming is creating pockets of
water that are exceptionally warm.
That changes the wind patterns, and leads
to more rain in those areas.
This is what environmentalists mean when
they talk about ‘Climate Justice’.
Madagascar produces just 0.01 percent
of all global carbon emissions - but look
what's happening.
That issue is going to be
on the table at COP26, the major U.N.
climate summit that's happening in
November.
Right now in Madagascar, humanitarian
groups are working hard to get food to
the people who need it most. But the
bigger questions aren't going away.
Like how we make sure millions more
don't starve because of what we're doing
to the planet.
If you're interested in the debate about
how to protect the environment, check out
our recent Start Here episode on Ecocide.
And be sure to subscribe to Al Jazeera
so you don't miss our new episodes. And
if there's a topic you think we should
be covering, let us know in the comments.